un long silence voilà ce qu'ont obtenu
de la part de l'exécutif les
journalistes du monde entier qui ont
participé à l' enquête sur le logiciel
pegasus encadrés par forbidden stories
pour rappel ces investigations menées
par un consortium de journalistes ont
révélé qu'il y a une dizaine de jours
qu'en 2019 les numéros de téléphone
portable du chef de l'état et de
certains membres du gouvernement en
exercice à l'époque avait pu être mis
sous surveillance par le maroc grâce au
logiciel espion israélien pegasus si les
faits sont avérés ils sont évidemment
très grave avait réagi l'elysée
depuis plus rien le silence de l'elysée
dans la sphère pegasus est
incompréhensible le monde a fait la
liste des questions d'intérêt public
auquel le pouvoir ne répond pas il
suffit de la lire pour comprendre que ce
silence cache quelque chose
en effet le quotidien le monde rapporte
que malgré leurs sollicitations
régulières l'elysée refusait toujours de
répondre à leurs demandes car le journal
a pu en collaboration avec le
laboratoire de sécurité d'amnesty
international faire analyser le
téléphone de l'ancien ministre de la
transition écologique
françois de rugy selon le quotidien son
terminal ne comporte aucune trace
d'infection mais des signes de ciblage
en provenance a priori du maroc
amnesty international a partagé sa
méthodologie afin qu'on france des
analyses puisse être effectué par l'ansi
l' agence nationale de la sécurité des
systèmes d'information aucune nouvelle
depuis sur les résultats des analyses
déplore le monde
le journal a donc publié une liste de
questions posées par la sphère pegasus
restées sans réponse alors qu'elle
relève de l'intérêt public
en voici quelques unes le téléphone
portable des manuels macro at il été
infectés par le logiciel pegasus si oui
des informations sensibles ont elles pu
être intercepté emmanuel macron
utilise-t-il ce téléphone pour des
échanges sensible confidentielles ou
même classé secret défense
confirmez-vous que le maroc est bien à
l'origine de ces opérations de ciblage
comment qualifiez-vous dans ce cas
l'attitude du maroc pays amis des
journalistes des avocats et plus
largement des citoyens français ont vu
leur téléphone ciblés par le logiciel
pegasus
ciblage portant la signature du maroc
quelle réponse la france entend tel
apporter à cette violation des droits
élémentaires de ses ressortissants un
silence obstiné en guise de fin de
non-recevoir donc alors que les
premières analyses techniques menées par
la police judiciaire confirme que
pegasus a bien été actionnés pour
espionner des français selon france info
un journaliste de france 24 ainsi que
deux autres de mediapart qui ont accepté
de faire analyser leurs téléphones ont
bien été les cibles d'une attaque grâce
au logiciel pegasus